so I had an idea once again this was
just a tiny bit of a random stream
really I wasn't really feeling like
working on the let's play park and like
the good old times of designing to just
build a random cathedral I kind of
decided to not work on the let's play
park take a tiny bit of a break from
that and try building a palace now
there's a couple of things you probably
need to know about this this was mainly
kick-started by looking at Leonidas
photo book its page which was amazing
for all of you people don't know
Leonidas I always like to fangirl over
whatever he makes him he's really good
when it comes to making buildings and I
was just kind of skimming through his
photo bucket page his library at least
that's what it's called and it just
found loads of awesome stuff over there
and just got too inspired to not try
some stuff out for myself like there was
some sort of touch ish though I don't
know for sure if I can really say it
like that
there was a pretty low palace that I
found over there which cool which gave
me some ideas of what pieces I should
really use in the game and what types of
stuff I should try and then there was a
bit of a Google search for palaces and
getting some general ideas on what I
wanted to do and kind of got a clear
sort of idea which doesn't really sound
very clear at all let me rephrase that
got an idea in my head of what sort of
Palace I wanted to make and dishonor to
just get into the game start streaming
and see if anything good came out which
I think eventually it sort of did though
I do have to say this before I really
got too much into it it's gonna take
quite a while I think it's gonna be
three videos until the palace itself is
even finished and then I still want to
add some simple gardens around that
nothing spectacular when it comes to the
gardens but just something of a little
con and little context to place the
building and really so that's going to
be that also this is an last thing I
recorded it was very early in the
morning and I'm currently recording at
midnight so there you go has some
interesting recording times and don't
know if that really influences your mu
stuff like people always say well when
it comes to commentaries on YouTube when
it comes to Let's Plays and all that
stuff you
always have to force yourself into the
same mood and I've caught at the same
time in stuffing that [ __ ] I'm a
person too in any case what I should do
and what I should what I never do what
always takes me way too long it's
actually talked about the building
itself and past that little introduction
of basically what got me into it and
this building is supposed to be a bit of
a gothic / eclectic but then again also
a bit of a classical
white palace at least that's the very
idea that that stone part over there is
really just going to be the base of the
building the rest of the building I want
to get slightly white although I must
add that on to this video I did change
the color scheme to a more brownish
looking color scheme since that really I
mean at the end of this video
unlike the palace I just wasn't too sure
about the colors itself and changing it
to more and more of a bigger variety of
colors not just white really brought out
the depth in the building since as you
can see there are already quite a lot of
details on it and but yeah since they
all have the same color it doesn't
really work out as well as I kind of
blend it to so that was something that I
probably would have kept in mind if I
know that if I knew that beforehand but
yeah the console is going to consist of
one main part with a large tower in the
middle with small towers on the sides of
that main parts and two wings on the
sides where I'm honestly still I don't
know for sure if I want to add any more
towers I kind of want to keep it to
three main towers with him tower in the
middle by far being the highest and the
largest hour and really the center point
of the overall building and the wings
and the towers on the sides just kind of
to add some mass to that and get that
sort of shape to the building where it's
starts very low on the sides and very
low profile and builds up towards the
middle where you have that signature
kind of thing in the middle and that's
basically how that kind of works and
this was honestly also a bit of an
experiment when it comes to mixing sets
and finding specific thing finding
specific pieces that I wanted to use for
certain stuff which is always actually
sort of fun
though I must add it's it's probably
only fun when you actually know the SATs
that you need to use for specific pieces
but it's just kind of fun to look at
stuff to look at real life castles see
what sorts of objects or sets you have
to use to emulate certain things since
obviously in Rolla Co second three you
can't exactly get everything and in the
way that you wanted to have you can't
exactly get the Gothic arches that a
real big palace would have in real life
so you kind of need to emulate the same
sort of look with objects and that's
basically what it comes down to it never
comes down when it when it comes to
mixing sets it never comes down to
looking at pieces and figuring out what
can I do with that
it's rather than it's the reverse having
some sort of image of what you want to
do and then seeing whatever piece you
can use to achieve your look which is
really also what kind of happened over
here though I must say there are a
couple of things that I don't really
have that for and if you if you do pay
attention to it you'll find that some
pieces really occur quite often in this
building and even for different things
for example in Main Street - there is
the roof support piece and fix the roof
support and piece in any case it's a
pretty large cornice looking support
piece that has a vertical support on one
side and at the top of it it has a very
large horizontal square which is
actually used to top of those pillars at
the bottom but it's also used the top of
the arches that on well I was just
building and it's even used in the arch
of the main entrance which is also has
quite some pieces in there but yeah that
was actually my main inspiration from
the unites since he was actually the
person to use Clint's arches I don't
know if it was really the first to do it
in that way but use claims arches and
combine that with the main street sets
actually get a much better arch than I
expected I honestly always just threw
away the idea of using Clint's arches in
anything but anything 2010 since it
really doesn't look too realistic and it
didn't seem too useful in any building
talk to me but it really turned out that
Clint's ouches was just great when it
comes to this stuff
also this buildings get me really hot on
the custom scenery requests so if
there's any sort of specific piece that
you're looking for in the building and
as always don't hesitate to ask but it's
gonna be really really tough since there
are quite a lot of pieces and but yeah
that's that's mainly why I also built
this building to just experiment with
custom scenery and see if I could even
pull off something like this which I've
honestly tried before but and I haven't
tried it in a very long time so I really
felt like doing it once again and when
it comes to that roof by the way
sometimes it's nothing more but just
trial and errors just placing something
and figuring if it really works like at
first I had Mabel's Gables I think for
the roofs which is a really good set and
its own right really amazing for things
like Main streets but it really just
came out to light in the end for this
building and almost too distracting
since that is also something that I kind
of wanted to go for I what I already had
so much detail on that middle section of
the building with all the arches and the
windows and the decorations on it so to
sort of distract from that I really
wanted the roof to not have too much
detail on it and to not have too much of
a similar color and of course also the
lower layer where it has still has these
stone walls to not be too distracting
and really keep the primary focus on the
middle area and that's kind of how that
works as well and this is where it gets
really tricky and by tricky I really
mean really tricky since I I basically
had sort of an idea in my head for both
the towers on the sides and the tower in
the middle but this is almost where it's
pretty much almost necessary to always
combine sets and just get whatever the
hell you can even to get a certain look
which is at the same time I think the
good part about this building but then
again also its down form which I'll get
to in a second actually over here
basically what
I always try to do whenever I build
towers like that is try to get a certain
look and this is really when it comes to
trying to emulate a certain look using
custom scenery pieces since from a
distance you can clearly tell what sort
of roof this is on the towers on the
sides very narrow roof with many details
in it on it but if you zoom in on roofs
like this you can clearly see that oh
hey he used a castle topping piece from
the world Disney World Council set over
there there's even some weird things
sticking out that don't really belong
there but do belong to another custom
scenery piece that I needed to get this
shape and essentially in the end and I
think this counts for the towers on the
sides but especially for the tower in
the middle
I got a sort of shape that I really
wanted for the roofs but the details on
it themselves are just kind of awkward
when you find out what certain pieces
were used for it like for example on
those little towers on the roofs and I
did use and the top pieces of the towers
from the world Disney World set and they
what in the world world will hold on a
second from the Walt Disney World set
which has the main Cinderella castles
pieces but you can also see that there
is some weird things sticking out and
that there is a little weird dome which
are used to top that that part off and
that there are that there is actually
some sort of weird gothic looking tower
piece at the top of that little tower
like nothing to get really really too
complicated in any case there is just
there is so much stacking going on with
customs increases that even though I got
this shape that I wanted to have for the
roof it just came out looking a tiny bit
realistic especially when you zoom in on
it and that's really what I sort of mean
with the fact that custom scenery there
is this big it's not really it's a boob
at this big thing about combining custom
scenery but sometimes it's a bit of a
negative thing as well there is such a
thing as trying to combine too many
things and eventually ending up with
some sort of objects that looks more
like it's a random mess of
things then really what you're trying to
go for and that's part of what I think
it's the bad side about this building
but then again I really feel like on the
front facade
it really works very very well but
especially on the middle tower as you
can see it's it's starting to turn into
a complete tower fest with all sorts of
random little details on it and
balconies and things just to make it
look interesting from a rollercoaster
country perspective and especially from
far away where I think that this tower
looks quite good when it comes to and
looking at it from a distance but when
you zoom in on the details it is just oh
my is so painful to look at so yeah this
is this by no means means that I really
want to just scratch this building I'm
quite happy about it it's just a bit of
feedback that I would like to give
myself in hindsight and also the viewers
I suppose also the main idea actually
got quite many comments about what this
building or is supposed to be like
somebody said I think the city hall in
Brussels which I can really see there is
quite a similarity with that especially
the the shape of the tower one of my
main inspirations was actually the
Palace of freedom in The Hague which you
might definitely not see looking at this
building straight away but I just kind
of view it for myself in the main tower
and especially with the wings coming up
in the end it kind of looks like that
but it really is I think it was also
what town is that again some other
Belgian town that there's loads of
buildings in the world actually that
looked like this in any case and that's
it for this episode really random I know
but I just felt like building this
palace and I think like I said when I
was building that Cathedral sometimes
you just have to do whatever you feel
like doing it
which I often do in rollercoaster 3 but
I hoped that this was recorded worthy
whether it was or not I'll leave that up
to the people here but I need to end
this video already damn it
there he goes in before there he goes
silver at dislikes his own outro which I
do this is this is by no means a good
way to end the video
but it is I have to end the video so
I'll be the saying guys and then I'll
see you in the next video of this series
I suppose otherwise let's play roller
coaster three years City skylines or
whatever bye